hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to corpse party now this is
the RPG horror game that you guys voted
for above all else it beat out Mesa by
almost 2 to 1 you guys really really
wanted me to play it so here I am now
this game as with most RPG horror games
is all about the story please ensure
your speakers are turned up this the
sound in this game is designed to
enhance your experience as our most
horror games or at least they should now
because this is a very story driven game
there's gonna be a lot of narration to
it and I'm gonna try to give myself the
best possible playthrough for you guys
to watch in terms of an experience on
how the story flows how the narration
goes you're gonna get a lot of my sexy
narration voice in here and I'm gonna
just try to make this as thorough a
playthrough as possible I know like with
most things the endings are multiplied
there are various different things that
I can do throughout the game so if I
make a mistake I am I am very sorry I've
never played this game before in my life
and I'm gonna try to do my best
hey have you heard what happened in this
school that's right back when this
school is being built a girl no one
older than us was hanging around the 3rd
floor when suddenly crack she fell split
her head open and died hello and after
that do you know what happened to the
girl um
they held a fumarole and cremated her no
no no when she cracked open her head
everyone thought she was dead she jumped
up and started repeating more over and
over cackling with laughter and then she
disappeared doc doctor harlot she was
gone only leaving behind the top of her
head in her blood so I guess you could
call her missing missing you're joking
it was a rainy after school day just
like this wait who's that
who are you kidding that was you wasn't
it what that wasn't me
oh no yeah well who was that sorry that
was me who that ear piercing scream was
produced by machi de can't say I'm
surprised no no I meant to say it was me
before a bit of a coward huh guess they
haven't dropped yet huh
oh okay there we go ah
so just telling horror stories in the
dark when it's raining outside huh
enough of that we came here for the
school festival and not for ghost
stories jeez I can't believe how much we
have left to do and it's already past
time for us to head home yeah come on
guys we don't want to be here till dawn
figures the two scaredy cats would team
up against me shut up and work move it
move it we got to wrap this up
okey-dokey
me and shinozaki will work on decorating
Satoshi kitchen Numa would you mind
moving the desk back all right I'll give
it a try yeah yeah so Who am I playing
here and also I wanted to state that
this game is most likely oh man why did
everyone else get to ditch out on this
why is it just us just a little fact of
life people suck nothing we can do about
it we have to follow the class reps
orders if it wasn't for her I'd be at
home sleeping in a warm bed yeah yeah it
sucks no one wants to be here let's just
do it now now no use complaining about
it let's just finish up and go home well
everyone seems to be talking for a while
but no one's actually doing anything huh
a power outage bad timing huh guess we
can't do anything now what what about
that candle from earlier I have it
around here somewhere maybe inside one
of these desks hmm hello
why did the rain stop whose knock knock
knocking who's there hmm someone's at
the door
Satoshi you want to get that hey come on
be a man you sly bastard
oh I am moving now okay I'm finally
actually playing the game so like I said
I was trying to say before that there
was gonna be these are actually gonna be
longer episodes I'm coming in oh hi big
brother huh Yuko what are you doing here
you were gone for so long so I thought
I'd come pick you up and you forgot your
umbrella here now you're right I'm sorry
Yuka you're such a sharp girl that's a
reward I'll treat you to some crepes
later very French of this Japanese game
I knew it dot dot dot
is she a middle schooler yeah this is
Yuka my younger sister good evening
thank you for taking care of my big
brother she's adorable wow I can't
believe I didn't know you had such an
adorable little sister Satoshi yeah haha
well she's in junior high you know I got
it why don't I help out seriously if you
know mine then alright the more manpower
we got or a little girl power the faster
it'll go let's move tada
all done thank you everybody for helping
out there you really love your ghost
stories of course I wouldn't miss out on
an opportunity to spook everyone and
that's why we get to hear them over and
over huh dot dot dot
they're gonna be a crap look at the time
it's past 8:00 hey we're all done here
fantastic that means you can get over
here and help us yay oh boy
huh another power outage
wait did anyone else hear a strange
voice no no no no no I didn't hear a
thing are you trying to scare us again
shinozaki no I swear I heard something
wait a second you hear that what thud
what's that sound sounds like an organ
maybe it's from the music room hold up
who would be playing music in this
school this late at night no should we
go check oh no I'm not being the guinea
pig again what if it's some bloody
headless girl from like from shinozaki
story but aren't you curious
let's check suit yourself
or let's not I don't want to go alone
don't forget it
bye have fun in death because you're
probably not good return to us I'm going
after her okay also bye have fun and
also death come on everyone there's
always strength in numbers mochi to
bring you go along oh I guess we're all
going wandering in our own death come on
little sister I'm sure you're gonna be
nice and safe here hey you gonna come
with big brother
come on Yuka let's go come on
now the game actually starts and that is
getting louder definitely coming from
the music room give me the creeps
let's get moving yeah
hello what's going on this is definitely
a very dialogue heavy game Satoshi
everyone what happened oh my god what
the hell is going on it's all building
blowing up are we going into another
dimension err what happened ow ow ow
what the what happened Yuka Naomi
Yoshiki shinozaki someone answer me
lost a satoshis guy all alone damn got
to be a light or something around here
somewhere
oh yeah that candle from earlier huh
this classroom this is a classroom but
mm-hmm
what's with this desk ah there we are
what's going on here well then hello
things have gone horribly horribly wrong
already I love it Naomi it's you right
Naomi okay I got to go out this way all
right we have officially started the
game that was very dialog heavy in the
beginning but thanks for bearing with me
I mean as usual with these RPG horror
games they're gonna be very dialog heavy
so hope you guys don't mind that I mean
if you've already watched a few you know
that what the case is gonna be like hey
Naomi hang in there what am I supposed
to do I can't move hello where are we
who knows I can't make heads or tails of
what's going on wash hold on where are
we what's going on I'd love to answer
that as well hello are you my youngest
sister Yuka you okay love the music
going on very psychotic hey now try
those tears everything's gonna be okay
all right
but maybe not oh there they are
everyone's not dead found him yo you
guys doing okay yeah we're fine thank
God the gang's all here yeah but what
happened what's wrong nothing I think
she's just a bit scared
all right so let's just collect our
thoughts on what the hell happened no
good it's too dark to see outside in the
windows jarred shut what that makes no
sense damn it ah Yuka something seems to
be written over here mind reading it
over there I guess hello what did it say
you're not gonna read it just keep it to
yourselves it looks like a newspaper
what's it say it's dated September 24th
1926 wait a minute that can't be right
where are we
no this is all wrong someone's a right
it's okay you mean we're all here for
you
dot dot dot yeah Thanks so you're the
one that's gonna lose it that's right we
just got to find an exit then we'll be
able to go home and sleep in our own
beds that's Naomi the level-headed one
what the hell makes you dam so damn sure
well would you rather stand around here
and stare your shoes right let's search
for an exit okay Wow we'll just come to
school inch by inch a window a door
something has to give absolutely I agree
how about everyone else
I'm with Makita me too well for
searching from top to bottom we may want
to split into two groups
we should check up on every other on
each other every so often wind up date
with any new details that's not a bad
idea what do you guys think
split up I'm not so sure we'll be fine
we'll all be back soon are you really
frightened miss scary story lover get a
hold of yourself how do you think I feel
scary stories and scary situations are
entirely different concepts back to the
matter at hand there's five of us so I
guess we got to have a group of three
and two
okay would you like to view the
character bios now I'm good well maybe
you guys would touch a character read
their bias when you're done please touch
the bottom right desk oh I'm an eyeball
see Satoshi mo kita okay you guys can
read these I mean this is just gonna be
more information about the characters if
you guys want to read it I want to make
sure that you guys have the best
understanding of this game possible so
be sure to pause if you want to read
more understand and I'm just skimming
over it and I already have a good idea
what these characters are all about so
that's the younger sister she shouldn't
even be here spoiled by her family all
good to go everyone ready let's get into
this this is where the game really
begins so hopefully this is where
everything is started and we can
actually go into this how should we
split this I'm fine as long as I'm with
my big brother sorry I didn't mean for
that to come out besides the little girl
she is burping nakhon Nakashima you
should head out with Satoshi I'll take
her of shinozaki I'm a bit worried about
her
hey sure all right we were ready to go
just the two of us will we be safe don't
worry about it I got your back I'm a
strong man all right meet back here in
30 minutes don't do anything reckless
same goes for you yeah I got two lovely
ladies following you
thanks one of which is my sister so you
shut up about that okay so here we go I
got a party of three now the game is
officially begun well I didn't mention
that these episodes are probably gonna
be 30 minutes at a time because I want
to make sure that you guys get the best
story out of it possible Big Brother
here what's this it's my good luck charm
please take it
sorry but you keep it I can't take
something so valuable from you you car
you crying
Big Brother you're so thick-headed
sometimes it worries me I don't want you
to not have it because if you don't take
it fine God the first choice of the game
and I haven't even done anything yet
Thank You Yuka okay so I got you kiss
charm I would rather she'd have it but I
guess me having is good to you
something to form a kind of bridge well
you got it let me go find a board that I
can pry up with my bare hands
anything maybe I could put my little
sister down across and we could walk on
her face I might hurt her but at least
we get across she already gave me the
good luck charm so what do I need her
for okay so there's got to be something
else here that I can get something out
of these cabinets something to form a
bridge maybe hey do you have anything
they'll form a bridge anything at all
anybody anybody have anything anybody
have anything oh god am I lost already
have I somehow managed to find a way to
get lost even though I just started the
game whoa some kind of loose board on
the floor there we go got a loose board
thought that might have been something
someone take this summer I carry on my
way I've learned a lot of knowledge from
playing these RPG horror games I think
there's some sort of sprint ability okay
if you hold down the use button you can
actually be some sort of sprinting how
about that board we picked up earlier
would that work yeah that's why I picked
it up so lay it down smarty pants let's
go come on moving forward keep this
story flowing oh boy it's getting dark
yeah come along little guy I got my team
ready to roll c-can I go in here hello
monsters around anybody wanna kill me oh
good the lights went out I'd like to
music seems kind of energetic techno
punk now this game was actually made way
away a long time ago back when there's
like this RPG technology of the graphics
of this was actually on par with what
was going on the game gaming industry
that at the time so it's pretty wait
what would that say a massive long
tangled hair fell out ooh why why would
that be a thing and why is that such a
weird date at the 54th day of the 13th
month 1949 it's a big jump from the last
one but oh well I'm hoping then I'll get
some answers later on filled with yellow
liquid would it happen to be peepee
okay so carry on doors lock in it I
can't find a way to open it it's a
forbidden door I guess they really don't
want me to open it it budged it's jammed
won't lock forbidden door mr. forbidden
door oh my god a pile of Bones no I'm so
scared I ran out hang on head a pile of
bones oh wait a minute yes what is this
it's bones a human's bones no big
brother I'm scared you all who's there
you you all were dragged here against
you will weren't you the skeleton is
talking do you all understand where you
are can you tell us are you hold on just
what the hell are you I was as you are
now I was trapped down here against my
will and I will it away until I turn to
do what you see now for there are no
exits then where the hell are we
and we honest the wear is irrelevant it
is hardly even with asking you wouldn't
understand anyway because you are no
longer within your own world what do you
mean this is a world of hatred and
malice composed by the residual force of
vengeful spirits it leaks out and
creates enclosed spaces
the one you are trapped in dates over 40
years back naturally there is no way out
be glad you are not alone stick together
that way at least you can be with your
friends in the end unlike me
why did we have to be dragged down here
oh this ghost has a particularly strong
bond the real world
she calls anyone and everyone down here
even those unrelated to a death why why
the hell would she I do not know I don't
even know how to escape my own plight
however don't give up there has to be
something you can do something to break
free from this trap well you're being
awfully encouraging try not to end up
and he faded away big brother we can't
go home if we can go home right it's all
a lie right right I don't know
big brother listen to me big brother hey
hey hey come on tell me
tell me we can go back home see it'll be
fine you come why tell my little sister
to shut up give me your little good-luck
charm and shut the hell up it'll all be
fine yuca will be home soon we have to
stick together don't worry your big
brother is here right yeah I guess big
brother
let it all out yuca there there they say
got the brave one on my side Satoshi
seeing you with your sister like this I
may have to change my opinion of you
what were you thinking to be before is
that so huh come on Yuka I think we need
to get out of here it's not good for you
feeling better now
your eyes are still wet with tears I'm
okay alright come on let's head out no
need it for tough love here goodness
we'll definitely escape possibly we
don't know that yet that's still not
hundred percent guaranteed okay a
massive long tangled hair shed it fell
out again is what behind what's behind
you real is what's behind you really
real what's behind me
I don't know what's behind me a bunch of
old books okay
nothing important something on the wall
looks like shredded with sharp nails
it's impossible to read the sharp nails
have an evil demon girl who dragged us
down into the okay what is that that's a
pointer is that demon demonic demonic
myths missus and then they all died well
we better get moving
yeah come along I'll keep you safe my
name is I don't remember but we'll be
just fine
together so long as we stay together let
me actually see if there's a save okay I
want to make sure I save regularly
because if I don't I'm gonna be in a lot
of trouble okay so whoa no the hell it
rearranged it so at least I can go this
way so it looks like the two groups are
gonna be splitting up ooh there's gonna
be some sort of a double mechanic going
on here I need to make sure that I cover
all the ground possible before I
actually go anywhere so that one's
blocked off can't go that way don't run
in the halls mind your P's and Q's make
make sure your mind and use firm are in
order don't run in the house don't bleed
those are some pretty simple
instructions thank you for thank you for
clarifying that I mention this game came
out in 1996 I may haven't mentioned that
it was an old game but I don't think I
specifically said when was that by
touching the pentagram you can switch to
the other party thank you for the advice
helpful old man door appears to be
locked okay well there was another way
to go let me actually explore this area
fully before I switch to the other party
here I like I like games like this that
have a lot of reading because it gives
me a chance to actually exercise a good
voice I can do hey does something smell
kind of raw I think it's blood making me
sick Oh am I supposed to investigate
this
a fixed blast of blood is stuck to the
window thank you
hey guys there's a ghost oh okay that
wasn't there a second ago right we
totally ignored the fact that the ghost
is drifted by okay open oh hi please
that let that be a model
it's charted is vividly drawn entrails
they look like they're dripping skinned
on it you must be careful when detecting
first expose the subject to copious
amounts of salt water until the subject
swells then perform the incision if you
wish to continue the operation another
time apply more salt to the incision if
the subject becomes noisier screams Jim
claws in their mouth okay curl September
25th 1949 so now things are saying that
the from 1949 hello what are you it's a
human anatomical model it feels like
it's vacant eyes are following us good
good why is there so much hair packed in
these places it's weird don't do that it
moved the anatomical model wasn't there
earlier I don't know run escape the
science lab without touching me a
topical model ok but I'm gonna get
corner another day what are you doing oh
you can't go over that way oh I see so
so what about that am i dead
I like Donna my gonna die come on what
are you gonna do huh no daddy yep is it
loose bore on the floor yes of course
take that it's a good idea good very
useful can I put it there oh maybe I can
put it
I know you know you don't know we can
put it there no put it there yes I can
damn it am i dead forever okay good no
no no I was gonna make it out I didn't
understand the rules you get away from
her you [ __ ]
you let her go taking some damage you
cut out here says let her go that's
enough that's enough Kasumi run no no
I'm not doing that I'm gonna save you
I'm gonna save you bring it I'm gonna
smash that smug face of yours in which
to create speak with me Oh mate please
lo I'm gonna save you ish China maybe
[Music]
I've been killed game over
we're gonna pretend like that never
happen be right back guys okay take two
[ __ ] never catch me come over this way
yes yes you wish you could do this yeah
that's right no no yes no maybe yes I
don't know baby come on over this way
yeah come on follow me follow me yeah do
it do it do it come here follow me
kill him yes I did it I'm out buddy
thank you everybody I didn't get caught
at all ha ha ha ha never happened then
no one knew everyone was either thank
you very much
if the hell is that why do I have to go
through this crap it's my fault
Oh God don't you dare don't even think
about it bro
oh good clear can I save save yeah yeah
you like that was there any reason to go
in there there must have been another
reason oh god damn it's right there
again what's the point of this
who's the point of this it's all a bunch
of bull hockey it's all bunch of bull
baloney you know what I'm gonna go over
to the other team because at least they
appreciate what I do maybe a little bit
they probably don't appreciate that much
by touching Kapadia beards which the
other Peggy Sue it reminds me of
mechanics from Mad fob no not mad father
II when I was able to switch between the
two characters it's really awesome I
love it okay so either way I am going to
end this episode here because I am
preparing for my trip to New York and
hanging out with jontron so if you are
enjoying this let me know in the
comments below I'm gonna be recording a
whole bunch more so if you got advice
for me or stuff that I'm gonna you want
me to do I'm not gonna be able to read
it for a while but there are gonna be
more episodes coming every single day
once I get back from New York I might
even switch to one-hour episodes just so
I can get through this story for those
that really want me to get through it in
a timely manner so look forward to that
thank you everybody so much for watching
click the annotation more videos that
I've done check out more RPG horror
games that I play down in the
description and thanks again everybody
for watching and as always I will say
in the next video ba-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
friendly
Oh No
I don't want any when you go away